any type of danger right gives you this
slider fight response so train starts
with training jujitsu boxing Muay Thai
wrestling shooting competing competing
right you get used to those butterflies
when you compete you get those
butterflies and you get used to them and
so train and get used to seeing how that
reaction what that adrenalin feels like
and and also get used to understanding
what the superior action is right
fight or flight because sometimes flight
is the correct response sometimes fight
is the correct response but what you
want to do is you want to be able to
assess and dictate which response you're
going to give and not just do whatever
your instincts tells you because
sometimes your instinct might be wrong
and so again I don't know what you're
actually you're the situation we're
going into but whatever it is because
people get the fight-or-flight response
to do everyday things to like public
speaking right client rock climbing and
that's why I say you know do these
things training them so public speaking
rock climbing if you want to get good at
rock line we're gonna get over that
fight-or-flight response when you get up
go go rock climbing you're used to it
you scared of heights go start
parachuting you know you'll get used to
it you're scared of the water get worked
up and go through swimming and then give
come scuba certified just what the
things that you're not comfortable with
get comfortable with being uncomfortable
and while you're doing - while you're
doing them pay attention you got to
detach a little bit when these things
are when you're training detach a little
bit and see what is going on your
mindset see what red flags that you can
see what things will make you aware of
the fact that your nerves or your
adrenaline and your you you feel
yourself clenching your fists you know
okay so customized just be aware of it
so that you can change it so you can
adjust it and put yourself in put
yourself into these scenarios and
escalate them so they get harder harder
harder worse and worse and worse until
your
until you start to get control these
things